nous avons un plan merveilleux
qui fera de Buckhead City
la plus grande nouvelle ville d'Amérique
[Musique]
nous avons estimé qu'il y avait beaucoup de corruption, un
manque de transparence et beaucoup de crimes,
vous savez, nous avons eu des problèmes dans le
quartier qui  tu connais des gens dont tu
t'inquiètes les gens entrent par effraction dans
les maisons des gens donc tu es toujours sur
ta tête tu t'inquiètes pour la sécurité
étranger
avoir une réponse à nos appels au 9-1-1
est en quelque sorte classé comme étant raciste
c'est ridicule
nous sommes
ravis et fiers d'être afro-américains
et d'être majoritairement afro-américains, mais
cette excellence ne fait qu'ajouter à la culture
de notre communauté, nous avons certainement l'impression que
nous sommes un exemple pour de nombreuses autres
communautés, quelle que soit la race,
qu'elles peuvent certainement être une ville  tout comme
nous et prendre soin de leur communauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]